this is the motherboard for the Super
Nintendo a 16-bit video game console
that came out in 1991 in America and
these are the sound chips that worked in
tandem to create all the audio sound
effects and music that you heard in
Super Nintendo games the first check the
SMP or the SPC 700 was a processing core
where a video game musician could
essentially write the program that would
tell the other chip the DSP what sounds
to me whereas the original NES sound
chip had just 5 channels and could
really only do creative variations on
the same basic sound the Super Nintendo
had eight dedicated channels and used a
sampling system which meant that artists
could load in noises or sound effects
from instruments of their choosing with
room for 8 simultaneous instruments and
the ability to sample different sounds
the Super Nintendo was a big improvement
over its predecessor but there was still
one huge limitation between the two
chips the system could only accommodate
for 64 kilobytes of audio Ram to give
you a sense of how small that is an
average 3 minute mp3 song that you might
buy on iTunes is around 6 megabytes
which is a hundred times the size of the
super Nintendos full capacity and that's
just for one song the 64 kilobytes had
to hold all the music and the sound
effects for an entire game which is why
you often got music that sounded well
not that great what do you think of
sampling in popular music you might
think of someone taking a few seconds of
an old drum beat and using it in a new
song
but a sample that's even a few seconds
long carries a whole lot of information
in order to stay within the allotted 64k
Super Nintendo music samples had to be
the tiny often all the way down to a
single cycle of a waveform in order to
make good music with these limitations
you had to be creative
what you're hearing now is aquatic
ambience from 1994 Donkey Kong Country a
classic by one of videogames best
composers David wise wise was able to
ring beautiful music from the
limitations of the Super Nintendo sound
chips for example the evolving swimming
background pads that you're hearing in
this song sweeps like this just weren't
possible on the Super Nintendo and
sampling something this long and complex
would have quickly exceeded the capacity
of the system so wise had to think
outside of the box one of the most
important new features of the Korg wave
station is the ability to string
together a number of waves waves can be
defined as single or multi cycle loops
with more than 400 internal waves
available you can select up to 255
different waves to play in any order
including trace of pitch duration and
crossfade time wise took inspiration
from the Korg wave station a synthesizer
that came out in the early 90s and used
something called wave sequencing to take
a number of tiny samples and play them
in quick succession so that they made
unique evolving sounds of course the
Super Nintendo couldn't arrange and
rearrange samples on its own so in order
to achieve this effect wise
painstakingly recorded individual
waveforms at different frequencies and
placed them all in the coding program
one by one this program by the way is
called a music tracker where music is
essentially boiled down to numbers each
tiny sound is placed on a vertical
timeline and the columns represent your
know octave sample choice volume and
some simple effects like panning fade
and echo it took wise five full weeks to
input every sample for aquatic ambience
it's a tedious process but the results
speak for themselves
[Music]
[Music]
the Super Nintendo was a restrictive
system for composers there's no doubt
but as with anything limitation breeds
creativity and just because the sound
system consists of two chips 64
kilobytes of RAM and a lot of
hexadecimal code doesn't mean it can't
make beautiful music
[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody thank you so much for
watching this episode was brought to you
by Verve if you don't know Verve is a
service that pulls together a lot of
great content channels like roosterteeth
mondo crunchyroll and Funimation all
into one place so you can watch some of
the best anime there but they've also
added new channels like movie which
hosts a rotating roster of 30 indie
movies which is something that I love
another show that I would personally
like to recommend is Gary and his demons
about a dude who is destined to fight
demons but doesn't really want to do it
it's it's a funny show kind of like Rick
and Morty feel like that with Verve
premium you can get ad free access to
Gary and his demons and everything else
all the channels and for a limited time
you can use the first link in the
description to get a 30-day free trial
of Verve definitely try that out thanks
guys I'll see you next time